rough times out there folks uh rough
times for everyone but you know what
mike
nobody is handling it worse than
jimmy fallon oh my god this
jimmy [ __ ] phallus
baby let me set this clip up a little
bit please do so
jimmy has been hurting in the ratings
for quite some time
colbert's killing him um and
he's he is for a while pretty been
pretty steadfast in
trying to stick to the old school uh
method of like look i just want to bring
celebrities out and ask them stupid
questions about
their favorite recipes and [ __ ] and i
just want to do that kind of show
and he's had a series of
people come and go now from the staff
from nbc
now they're starting to tinker with him
and they're going like you need to be
more politically evolved and you ought
to be more woke so now jimmy
is being forced out at gunpoint to do
these little things he doesn't want to
do them
he doesn't want to do this and it's so
much this does look like a hostage video
you're right it already looks like a
hostage video
here we go well these are difficult
times to do an entertainment show
these are difficult times to do any show
but these are also times when we need
each other the most
it wasn't i i i've been pausing early
and i want to apologize it's fine
because i wanted to say something too
yeah so let's sorry it wasn't a
difficult time when they were burning
down minneapolis
it wasn't a difficult time when they
were burning down every small business
it wasn't a difficult time then now
because the precious
capital was being ransacked now it's
difficult times
and you know what i'm sorry but when
people that are dressed up as minotaurs
are storming the nation's capital
um and a dude in a brick suit and all
these other
like jimmy i hate to break this to you
but if you're finding that
now as a time in america where you're
finding it hard to be entertaining
you have no business being an
entertainer i'm sorry
there's no excuse ryan long's
entertaining danny paw chuck's
entertaining
we're entertaining dick masterson's
being entertained there's plenty of
shows that are
taking what's happening and going well
let's try to be as funny
lily singh has been firing on all
cylinders
did you see there's a new one on peacock
there's like a black check show for real
it's almost like a like a nighttime show
like a late night show
it's like some talk show but it's like
this black chick and it's boy is she
quirky
she's real quirky right she's very
quirky very quick see how quirky is she
gonna scale from one to annoying
annoying
yeah that's very quirky all right look
jim look jimmy han
jimmy i just got so jimmy's uh he's
getting up there now
jimmy i just finished a coke bender
fallon let's see what he has to say
these are difficult times to do any show
but these are also times when we
need each other the most and times like
these i think to myself oh my god he's
so mad at this
he's so bad he's so bad at the fake
sincerity thing
like dude some people nail the fake
sincerity thing
some people are amazing at it and then
other people
when you when you find yourself like
well i mean you saw him on snl he wasn't
a particularly good actor i'm surprised
he's not laughing in the middle of this
skit
here we go these are difficult times to
do any show
but these are also times when we need
each other the most
and times like these i think to myself
how is this happening now you know what
you know what would make this monologue
even better
if it was johnny carson horatio sands
coming out of a pair of tighty whities
and just trying to make jimmy fallon
laugh
the whole time no keep going jimmy
horatio sans tidy whities
cowboy boots and a maga hat just
standing there
in like three inches from jimmy fallon's
face trying to make him corpse the whole
time
how's this happening how can this be
happening i don't know maybe it's cause
you're all smug
how can i help and being here tonight
and talking to you at home and
reassuring you that we're gonna be okay
and that this is not what our country is
about
is how i can help this is what happens
when there is no peaceful transition of
power
and what happens when there is bad
leadership this is not how you lose
if my grandfather i'm sorry didn't you
guys lose four years ago and your
politicians encouraged them to
burn the country down for four years
straight
you know like look i still think that
anybody that went to this dc march is a
[ __ ]
i still think that it was a stupid idea
i all that stuff's true
but i'm getting real sick and tired of
being gaslit into pretending that the
entire 11 months before that
hadn't happened of course that's the
part that bugs me like yes i agree the
people that stormed
that building at that time were wrong
they shouldn't have done it it was bad
optics and it looked very bad that being
said
at least everything was left intact and
not burning like
you know what i mean like you you heard
that the the the two capital police that
got suspended one of them because he was
wearing
a hat and the other one that took a
selfie and i'm like
wasn't the national guard doing the
macarena in the middle of a burning city
remember that yes i remember that
vividly because we played it on this
show [ __ ] man
this is what happens when there is no
peaceful transition of power
and what happens when there is bad
leadership this is not how you lose
if my grandfather were alive today and
saw what was happening in the country
that he fought for he would say
wait you replace johnny carson
if might well to be very replaceable
well conan who replaced leno well no to
be fair
uh he replaced leno who replaced conan
who replaced leno
good [ __ ] mess no he's like jimmy
fallon's like
you know if my if my grandfather were
alive today he would probably say to me
jimmy
you gotta go to rehab you gotta you
really gotta clean up man
can't live like this forever and saw
what was happening in the country that
he fought for
he'd be disgusted people walking around
with the
flag upside down thinking they're
patriotic
but burning the flag at black lives
matter rallies
that's fine there's no consistency with
these people
again look if jimmy fallon was also on
here and not sucking black lives matter
dick
and when all this was happening then you
go look he's consistent at least he was
really talking about burning minneapolis
down burning but you were on their side
you were on their side when they were
doing it
at least be consistent
today was not patriotism today was
terrorism so what about
the people chanting kill all cops and
setting fire to small businesses
burning down a police precinct um
murdering
uh retired police officers for
television sets
annexing an entire portion of a major
city that's all fine
that wasn't terrorism
whatever happened to don lemon saying
that's you know who says pro
or was a como who says protests have to
be peaceful since when
hey look i'm just trying to tell people
oh here we go
uh that if the moons want to go out
there
and they want to burn down your store
let them burn down your store
why are you being a jerk i thought that
president-elect biden president biden
said it best when he said we have to
step up
well no he's president-elect biden um
he's still president-elect
and this is what he looks like right
after the show after he gets in his
bedrooms
uh he's president that's what he looks
like when he goes up to women
at sullivan's and goes i'm jimmy fallon
i'm famous uh this is what he says we
got to step up no you know you're right
because there was a peaceful transition
of power when trump won right that was
peaceful
you guys didn't have maxine waters
saying that if you see a trump supporter
on the street you should harass them
uh you weren't talking about purging
them from
society you weren't calling everybody a
nazi and then saying we should still be
punching nazis
you weren't doing any of that stuff
right you didn't slander
you didn't start slandering people that
make sure that they couldn't go eat at
restaurants
you weren't bot you weren't bothering
ted cruz when he was at a restaurant
with his family
you weren't doing any of those things
you guys were good little angels
to pretend like what and again what
these [ __ ] morons did in washington
dc because say what you want at least
you had the moral high ground
but these [ __ ] morons in washington
dc was even
close to what black lives matter did to
all of these cities and burning them to
the [ __ ]
ground to compare those two and think
that this was worse
is ridiculous the only reason that
they're losing their minds is because
and we said this before
we've said it on the show it's like they
didn't care because it wasn't them
they didn't care because they weren't
the ones directly dealing with angry
people screaming at them
they didn't care because washington dc
was a safe haven where they were left
alone and nobody bothered them
the moment somebody started bothering
them all of a sudden it's an
international crisis
all of a sudden it's when all of a
sudden it's the biggest thing in the
world gloom tube
gloom tube covered every single second
of those riots on d
live every second burning people people
getting hit with stuff
people [ __ ] chanting kill police and
everything and their d live account was
crystal clear gloom tube covers this
arguably a less violent event doesn't
make it right by the way but a less
violent event
in dc and all of a sudden their channel
is completely gone
stop this again this goes back to the
gamer game that we're talking about it's
the same thing you're being disingenuous
and that's the problem
look i think the distinguished thing was
[ __ ] dumb i wouldn't recommend any of
my family have gone to that
but also i thought everything black
lives matter did was [ __ ] dumb
at least i'm [ __ ] consistent
we're at our best when we step up we've
seen it over and over again during this
pandemic from the front line workers to
the
cashiers at grocery stores to everyone
delivering food or raising money for
people who need it
all liberals all the heroes are liberals
by the way all the heroes are
left-wingers
there is no republicans that deliver
food there's no republicans that are
front-line workers
there's no republican doctors no they're
all liberal heroes
that's what they are i mean well no
you're right because all the republicans
got fired from their jobs
you're right we are best when we work
together and step
up oh now you're ready to work together
you're ready to work together now we're
good
we're good to work together what's my
favorite is they burn burn it burn it
burn it burn it okay hey guys why don't
we grow up
but president biden also said something
after a speech that hit me even harder
he said i went poopy in my pants
that would hit me pretty hard too jimmy
fallon could relate it looks like he's
gone poopy in his pants a few times
after some benders
he said enough is enough is enough well
first off
owen heart is enough i was doing hard
i was in the owen hart enough is enough
it's time for a change
and i believe that's what a majority of
this country has been saying
has been screaming well no a lot of this
country
has been screaming if you don't mind uh
all cops are bastards
um white people are cancelled
um stuff like that actually
calling as small business owners
colonizers because they [ __ ] own a
restaurant
god forbid yeah
enough is enough okay today was a
disgrace
today was disappointing but i know it's
another because
it's another day you had to do your show
of course it was disappointing
what did you do did you do karaoke with
justin timberlake again
how what did you do did you do another
skit where you're broke is that what you
did
the the fact that these [ __ ] people
can just pretend
like they haven't been far worse this
whole time
and the fact that a large chunk of the
country buys it
you want to call the people that what
they did in dc and breaking into federal
property
domestic terrorists that's fine i'm on
board
if you're going to call the people that
broke into walmart domestic terrorist
people
that wanted to target domestic
terrorists the people that burned down
the autozone
they're how come they're not domestic
terrorists why are they just
they're off the hook they're fighting
for racial equality dude
oh i get it a lot of people that went to
washington dc feel the same way just a
different race hey walt's white people's
turn to be ruined
i get it it was not a surprise
but it's important to remember that this
is not who we are i assure you
there are more good people than there
are no no no no
this let me tell you something jimmy
this is exactly who we
are this is what we've bred
what we've made and what we've done the
chickens came home to roost
that's what happened this is who we are
as a country
yeah you could keep saying this is not
who we are and if you cared about who we
are
you would have taken a stance like i
said when they were burning down cities
and killing retired black cops
you would have cared when they were
annexing entire cities
this is who we are and you want to know
why this is who we are
because you created the monster your
[ __ ] dr frankenstein you
and all the [ __ ] people around you in
hollywood and in the media
you made it this is who we are the
problem is is that
you now can't handle your creation
you made it you pitted people against
each other every time you turned the
news
cnn local news what wasn't enough every
new video game every tv show
every movie was you're bad because
you're white you're bad because you're a
man
you're bad because you like this you're
bad because you because
you have beliefs you made it you turn
this into what it is
and the same reason when you went on the
news and you were saying like
hey black people you see what whitey's
doing to you hey can you believe hey
black people you're gonna put up with
this
and then when they got mad and burned a
[ __ ] city to the ground
then you're like oh what did they do
this
why would where would they get this idea
because you
created it enjoy the monster you made
[ __ ]
and it's only gonna get worse it's not
gonna get better
if you think some [ __ ] 80 year old
dementia patient is going to change
things
you're [ __ ] more gone than he is yeah
and i mean i
i love this smug thing that people do
with their like
we're better than this folks like we
we're we're better than this
like america deserves but we kind of
don't deserve
better like we don't this country's all
mcdonald's and fentanyl overdoses and
jerry springer and wet ass [ __ ] and
like nice pro wrestling and nice
carnival like we're just a giant
carny country it's it just makes me
laugh when people go like
shouldn't we aspire to be better than
this and it's like since when though
like since when so stop
again we're not better than this you
can't rile people
up you want to talk about the whole
trump
you know he if you use that logic
right what they're trying to do to trump
with the right if you use that logic
what it what is the media responsible
for
they're responsible for what is we're up
to what's happening now
black lives right wing and left wing
your guys are responsible for this
you have been pushing this and turning
you turned a blind eye
for nine months to what black lives
matter was doing in this country
you turned a blind eye to it
but when it turned around and started
affecting you all of a sudden
you're just clutching at your pearls
shut the [ __ ]
up this is what you get and
not to be joker pilled but you get what
you [ __ ] deserve
and you can take away people's twitters
and you could take away their parlors
and you could take away their cell
phones you can take away their mean
communications
but unless you start taking away
people's lives
you're gonna make it worse you think
this is funny huh jimmy fallon's whining
on tv
you think this is funny yes exactly
they couldn't carry a tune to save their
lives exactly
by the way that line never gets quoted
and it's the best part of that scene
it's just out of nowhere he's like they
couldn't carry a tune
[ __ ] stop we have been talking about
this and people disagree with us people
agree with us and that's fine i don't
care
but we've been talking about what the
media's been doing since day one of this
show since
[ __ ] day one of this show and even
before then we're doing another show
and you wanted it you got it
you're not going to change people's
minds by taking away their voice
you're going to make more mobs if you
think gamergate was bad
what silicon valley is doing now is
going to make
gamergate look like a [ __ ] carnival
that's what's gonna happen you keep
playing this [ __ ] game people are
gonna get
more and more pissed and why do i think
that
because i've seen what you look at
history
when people feel disenfranchised they
group together even more
and people that normally just wanted to
go to work and coronavirus
you shut everything down so that's part
of it people just want to go to work
make a living and for the most part if
you let people
go to work make a living watch some
[ __ ] tv to relax
and be with their family ninety percent
of the time you're gonna be fine
if you leave people alone but you
couldn't leave people alone
and this is what you got congratulations
i look like dj khaled so i'm gonna say
it you played yourself
they just wanted to grill jimmy that's
all they wanted to do jimmy
all they wanted to do was go outside and
go to a restaurant and guess what
you didn't let them jimmy but that's
okay jimmy you're going to fix it
you're going to fix it all and good will
prevail
thank you for watching and by the way
good good will prevail hormones to kids
and [ __ ] third trimester abortions
yeah that's that's the
those are the good guys those are the
heroes you know what the best [ __ ] up
family the best part about this was you
know
fallon got done doing this and then he
was like
[ __ ] nailed it like you know that he
actually like thought
this is my big [ __ ] this is my big
moment like they might actually pull me
up and put me on the nbc news desk after
this i'm so good
he really he really thinks that i think
you're right at a poignant moment
he [ __ ] sitting there going like are
you [ __ ] kidding me they gave michael
strahan a journalist job and not me
they gave that [ __ ] football player
on the morning show good morning america
that's not really a joke yes you're
right that's a very very fair point it's
not exactly
we're not talking about the good morning
america days when it was like
charles gibson and diane sawyer it's
[ __ ]
michael strahan and some yeah they're
the good guys remember guys
they're the good guys